Hi, my name is Sydney Richardson.
I'm an iOS developer at Double Dutch
where we make mobile event apps.
I was originally studying art and
graphic design,
but I really loved math and science.
And when I went to college
my parents were like,
why don't you study something
within engineering?
And my graphic design teacher encouraged
me to look into computer science.
So, I took a class.
Since I've been here, we've been working
on our in-app direct messaging service,
where users at an event can
connect to people one on
one without having the barrier of not
having their contact information.
We use Xcode, and we've been we're
writing everything in Objective-C.
You face a lot of different problems,
including view problems, or
API connection problems,
core data, core location, and bluetooth.
But, first I looked at
Apple documents and
what do i need to know before I start
coding something with core data?
And they'll give you
the directions to get started.
If you're having a problem you can
just look it up on the Internet and
someone is bound to have answered it,
or someone is also going to
be in the same boat as you.
I think mobile programming is a lot of
fun because you can immediately see
it on your device, or you can
immediately impact your friend or you.